look i know it's the wrong spider-person
outfit but this is all i currently own
[Music]
well there's a new spider-man movie out
you know what that means
well first means i have to review it i
did that break room of geeks check it
out if you haven't already um but
that also means
i gotta rank these suckers
all nine of them the nine theatrically
released spider-man films i'm not
dealing with any of the
bundled together of tv episodes like
that were sold as live-action or
anything weird you know from other
countries i'm not yeah
none of that you know what the main
films are that's what we're talking
about why waste time let's get right to
it with number nine
spider-man 3.
uh look
i know that this has gotten a bit of a
critical reappraisal in more recent
times there's a number of youtubers who
i who i know and like who will defend
this film and i'm not even gonna say
that they're wrong but i
still
really don't think it works
like at all
if it works for you
fantastic it just does not work for me
and a large part of that just has to do
with what a major drop-off it was from
the previous films i mean there's the
stuff everybody talks about like venom
and how uh it makes peter really
unlikable and like you can defend that
as part of the narrative and that peter
being cool is gonna be cringy because
peter parker doesn't know what cool
actually is like i get that you can
defend that but that doesn't make it any
more fun for me to watch i still don't
like watching it but i don't even think
venom's that big of a problem i actually
really can't stand sandman i hate the
retcon to tie flint marco in to the
death of uncle ben i also just think
he's not a very uh captivating villain
like at all
and they wrap up harry's stuff really
haphazardly it's kind of a mess of a
movie
and even trying to go back and re-watch
it like there's bits here and there
there's performances that are good the
when um when sandman like pulls himself
together for the first time that's gold
but like
overall as a whole
no
just no
number eight
the amazing spider-man now i know most
people uh would consider this to be the
better of the two andrew garfield-led
movies i'm not gonna necessarily
disagree with that it's just that if you
were gonna ask me which one i would
rather re-watch i'd more readily
re-watch the second one i'll get into
some of the reasons why when i talk
about that one as for this one
it's not terrible it's not pa honestly i
spider-man 3 is the only one i
personally find kind of painful to watch
and a lot of that just has to do with my
own aversion to cringe style humor which
it leans on kind of heavily
this
it doesn't hurt me to watch it but there
isn't really that much that's
exceptional about it it's just
good enough
it's got a spider-man
look that is good enough it has special
effects that are good enough it has a
story that's good enough it has a
villain that's good enough
really the only thing that's
exceptionally good is while the
chemistry between uh peter and gwen
stacy and andrew garfield i think
especially when he's in the suit and
quipping is good in the role yes it's a
real knife my weakness it's small knives
but
most of the elements they're just fine
there is very little that raises this up
number seven the amazing spider-man 2
and the reason i put this one slightly
higher is there are some things in here
that i do think are genuinely good or at
least play really well for me first of
all
the suit looks freaking great
it looks awesome
i like the dubstep stuff with electro
is it corny yeah
but i do still kind of like it for some
bizarre reason
um i as much as like it hasn't been
properly built up to as an isolated
scene
death of gwen stacy's pretty well done
and i know i'm the only person on the
planet who with this opinion and i can't
really defend it
but i like the rhino
and i love the ending
and when i say the ending i don't mean
the death of gwen stacy i mean the very
ending
ending with spidey squaring off to
getting back into the groove and doing
what he knows he needs to do
after tragedy
i think that's a great ending
there's a whole lot else here that is a
mess harry comes out of absolutely
nowhere and they try and
well they basically try and have him pay
off the way that the original three
films tried to have him pay off and they
couldn't even pull that off and they're
just introducing him here for the first
time this really can't pull it off and
so much of it is so
transparently trying to set up other
movies that it does pull you out of it
and
electro is okay at least once he gets
his powers original flavor max dylan is
again it's the cringe humor thing
but there are at least some things that
i can point to and go that bit i
genuinely like that [ __ ]
number six spider-man far from home
this is really a personal taste one and
it's it's hard to nail down exactly why
this fell so short for me after
homecoming but it just
wasn't clicking again it felt like
you know what i think by and large it
felt like a much more
manufactured situation homecoming felt
like a very organic situation if peter's
going to be spider-man this is the kind
of stuff that is going to happen around
him that he's going to have to deal with
he's going to have to figure out what
sacrifices am i going to make to my
personal life to try and help people how
am i going to balance uh you know a
social life and school and this how is
this all gonna work and most of the
conflict that came out of that in that
film felt organic and natural whereas
far from home just feels yeah it feels
like the hands of the writers and the
directors manipulating everything into
place and it just didn't flow right
it's it's hard for me to nail down
anything other than that it's just a
bunch of things that just feel a little
off like they're not clicking as well if
i saw this in isolation i probably like
it better but
as a step down from the one that came
before a little bit like spider-man 3 if
i'd seen it in isolation i might have
liked it better than if it hadn't been
preceded by a much better movie so
yeah now i will say this far from home
is the last one that i have serious
caveats about from here on out
good stuff coming
number five
spider-man
the original
tobey maguire
not my favorite spidey
he's not he never will be but
for the kind of peter parker that this
is for the
wait because peter parker can be done a
number of ways
he's been done a number of ways over the
years and for the era of spider-man that
the movie wished to evoke and how peter
was in that era he was a solid pick
as much as i don't care for the green
goblin suit you can't knock willem dafoe
all the supporting cast is spot on oh my
god cliff robertson
as uncle ben
oh
oh god he's the best
he breaks my heart and he's the best
and it's just such solid working you
need to remember
the idea of a bright flashy colorful
slightly silly
superhero film
that wasn't really a thing
this is more a spiritual success for to
the original
christopher reeve superman than to
anything that had come out close to it
because the batman movies had gotten
silly but in a way that
nobody cared for but and it had started
that franchise in super dark x-men had
happened a couple years before and it
was just really black and like there's
reasons like that movie but this
was such a bolt of fresh air
and most of what i think those of us who
like the mcu consider to be the
strengths of the mcu
this is the template that they're
following
this was the film that said
no
it won't look silly for us to do a comic
accurate suit on our hero it won't be
too cartoonish or comic booky whatever
that even means to tell the origin how
it really was in the comics we can
translate this in a way that works for
film without having to completely
reshape it or or be ashamed
of what it was on the comic book page
that came from this the original
superman did it first but no other film
had done it since then and this really
kicked off and was the proof of concept
that this was going to be the future of
superhero films
and granted i went on a little bit more
about its legacy than its merits as a
film but like it matters okay we're into
the top floor and i gotta tell you
number four number three number two
are really close like hare's breath away
between these next three but the way
that i'm choosing to order them today
number four spider-man no way home
it's big
it's
meta
it's bonkers i'm not gonna get into any
of the spoilers it's too new but for
everything that it's doing for how long
it is this shouldn't work
but it does
it works really well and it's a really
satisfying film it is satisfying as the
closer for this little currently maybe
we'll get more spider-man films in the
future but this currently self-contained
trilogy
of the tom holland spider-man
i would like to see more from him
there's no reason we can't get more but
his contract is up unless they negotiate
a new one and if this is his final
outing it's a dang solid finish i can't
get into specifics i wish i could you
got to check out the review if you i
actually want to hear my thoughts on
spoilery stuff the one that i linked to
earlier so
for right now just know
it's a good movie it's a good time
and i really dug it
number three spider-man
two
oh man as good as that first spider-man
was
everything
was better here
i love willem dafoe as the green goblin
but you know what alfred molina as doc
ock
gold
absolute
solid
gold toby maguire feels a little bit
more at ease in the part here you know
as much as this very tightly round
version of peter is ever going to be at
ease all the things that were good last
time are still good but the action
scenes feel better and more self-assured
the set pieces feel bigger the stakes
feel more personal the danger feels more
immediate
everything has just been turned up that
little bit from a really good first
movie
and virtually everything in this one is
better than that
oh it was such a step up ah it's still
good still really good
number two
spider-man homecoming this is on the
strength of a number of things the two
big ones being i really love tom holland
as spider-man and i
love
freaking love
michael keaton
as the vulture
he is
perfect
and it's a brilliant reimagining of the
character it is just
um
and like all the other stuff this
younger version of aunt may which on
paper i was like that's a dumb idea i
love it
this
version of mj who is slightly sullen and
like borderline gothy almost at least in
attitude if not style it's like that
shouldn't work it does i love it ned is
ridiculous i should find him annoying
he's comic relief i love him
all these things are just perfectly put
into place and it has good judicious use
of iron man on top of that and so that's
a bonus honestly i remember first going
to this i was like is he going to
overtake this movie and suck the oxygen
out of the room no he's here to support
and buoy peter because this is peter's
story and it never forgets that
it was so good
but it should not surprise people
what number one is
and as close as i said
numbers two three and four were like
super close i could reorder those three
any number of ways and still be pretty
happy
but number one
into the spider verse
is god
damn
perfect
it's perfect
it's one of those things where
you know
it's funny when i see films sometimes
where like there's just little tiny
things that like maybe like yeah maybe
that little bit
what's funny is the effects of time
because one of two things will happen
either
those little things will with re-watches
or reflection bother me more and more
and more and more more and i will like
the film less as time goes on where i
may have enjoyed it on initial viewing
or
time will simply gloss over
any
thing that i had a slight niggling doubt
about before
and now
i see nothing
but beauty
i know i had tiny
tiny issues
with that film when i saw it i can
barely remember what they are now and i
don't have them anymore
miles morales
is an excellent spider-man in this film
and the way they're able to bring in all
these other spider characters have
everybody there and never ever lose
focus on this as miles
story even as other characters also have
arcs peter b parker especially but it
still keeps its focus this is about
miles this is miles's journey and the
freaking triumph
of him putting on his own suit
and swinging about in that for the first
time
it makes me stand up and cheer and pump
my freaking fist every
time it is
so good
and the animation is incredible the
villains are great as much as i gushed
about alfred molina this is probably my
favorite version of doc ock that has
actually ever been done comics animation
or film
it's just
amazing this thing
this should not work on just about every
level
this many characters first film at a
franchise like for as much bonkers stuff
that go as went on in no way home that
was a third film that was building on
existing stuff this
it is building on a certain amount of
assumed foreknowledge of what spider-man
is but it still covers the bases even if
you don't really know and it does so
much
so
tightly
so
seamlessly fluidly
just
smooth
just uh
hey
hey
that's how smooth it is
oh i don't know if i made my point or
undermined it with that
i'm not gonna worry about it we'll wrap
it up there
what's your order or at the very least
what's your favorite whatever your
thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it
like share and subscribe i have a
patreon so i pay my bills and keep this
whole operation up and running rewards
for every tier there's also a link in
the description links to other stuff as
well
twitch stream twitter various uh social
media things plus my p.o box you know if
you
wanna
send something spider-man themed so i
don't have to only wear the
the um ghost spider outfit i mean i love
it don't get me wrong but you know
don't worry about it either
because
ultimately
you
are the council
and i
only run the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
none of this would have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon in
particular i want to thank robin powell
raven mcbain tracy scrabbit vincent paul
bartolucci robin moore and shayla
gourley if you'd like to hear me
possibly mispronounce your name maybe
consider looking at the reward tears
over on the patreon
but either way don't worry about it too
much
take care of yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]